heute geht es um alle ahrens theorie des
bösen und
ich hatte schon gesagt in einer
vorherigen sitzung sie an hannah arendt
verstand sich nicht als philosophin
sondern als politikwissenschaftlerin
politik politische philosophin könnte
man sagen sie hatte dann in an der new
school for social research in new york
city gelehrt weil sie flüchten muss dem
zweiten weltkrieg ja weil sie jüdische
herkunft waren mit anderen exilanten
exzellenten hat sie dann dort gelehrt
new york
ein bild von ihr
und wir haben ein paar fragen die wir
uns jetzt hier genauer vornehmen wollen
nämlich wie charakterisiert hannah
arendt die person adolf eichmanns
bezüglich der frage nach dem bösen und
wie interpretiert haaren cantz begriff
des bösen und wie verhält sie sich dazu
das sind die fragen die wir uns heute
stellen wollte ich habe hier noch ein
paar
titelbilder von büchern von einer art
für sie noch vorbereitet
weil sie daran sehr gut sehen dass ich
ihre beschäftigung mit dem bösen weiter
zurück erstrecken sie haben hier auf dem
ersten vorgestellten im titelbild eine
ein cover einer die ihrer dissertation
aus dem jahr 1929 mit dem titel der
liebes begriff bei augustin und
augustinus hatten wir ja auch im kontext
des bösen schon behandelt ich mach oben
rechts und links dann rein zu dieser
sitzung
jedenfalls kannte hannah arendt ich sehr
gut aus auch mit der antiken philosophie
ein weiteres buch was sie
fast hat nicht direkt jedenfalls eher
ein bericht der sagt auch der titel ein
bericht von der banalität des bösen das
ist einmal in jerusalem es gibt es in
verschiedenen neuauflagen das ist adolf
eichmann willkommen noch genauer darauf
zu sprechen das war also ein prozess
adolf eichmann verantwortlich für die
organisation
des holocaust war und eine art hat
anlässlich des des gerichtsprozesses in
jerusalem mit ja darüber einen bericht
verfasst und aus dem lesen wir heute
auch einige stellen weil die sehr
interessant sind sind sie sich der frage
ob sich oder wie sich formen des bösen
gerade auch in modernen gesellschaften
zeigen und dann möchte ich noch ein
letztes karin nicht verschweigen die mit
hannah arendt über das böse das ist eine
vorlesung zu fragen der ethik dass es
aus dem nachlass herausgegeben dann und
aus diesen beiden
also habe ich mal in jerusalem und über
das böse da lesen alle texte sind
interessiert sich mit dem liebes begriff
bei augustinus und abends interpretation
zu befassen verdienen habe ich auch
proben rechts hier dann einen link
rheins einem seminar wo ich auch dieses
thema behandelt hat im rahmen von
philosophischen theorien der emotion
weil liebe ja auch eine emotion ist ja
also eine art ist sehr fruchtbar aus ihr
kann man sehr viele interessante
theorien heraus ziehen sie hat sie nicht
so ganz explizit entwickelt aber sie hat
sehr sehr gute gedanken
gegeben die sich lohnen weiter zu denken
ja und jetzt gehen wir mal hier auf
dieses erstgenannte buch von was ich
ihnen jetzt heute vorstellen möchte
genauer ein also adolf eichmann war wie
gesagt verantwortlich für die
organisation des holocaust und ihm wurde
dann er wurde dann gefangen genommen man
hat ihn entdeckt der weiß geflüchtet
untergetaucht und hat ihn dann
schließlich gefunden und vor gericht
gebracht und jetzt hatte hannah arendt
die etwas provokative formel der
banalität des bösen
entwickelt ja jetzt kann man sich fragen
warum sollte denn adolf eichmann danach
sei also im kontext dieses prozesses in
jerusalem mit über mit adolf eichmann
hat eine art diese dieses diese wendung
fallen lassen und hat dafür auch viel
kritik geerntet weil das doch so als
eine verharmlosung auch verstanden
werden können und jetzt leser mal hier
was ich dazu sagen eichmann war nicht
jaguar und nicht macbeth also dass seine
protagonisten auszuwirken von
shakespeare und nichts hätte ihm
ferngelegen als wird wie ich hat den
dritten zu beschließen zitat ein
bösewicht zu werden
aus einer ganz ungewöhnlichen
beflissenheit alles zu tun was seinem
fortkommen dienlich sein konnte hatte
überhaupt keine motive und auch diese
beflissenheit war an sich keineswegs
kriminell hätte bestimmt niemals seinen
vorgesetzten umgebracht um an dessen
stelle zurück er hat nur um in der
alltagssprache zu bleiben niemals
vorgestellt was er eigentlich anstellt
es war genau das gleiche mangelnde
vorstellungsvermögen das immer möglich
viele monate hindurch einen deutschen
juden im polizeiverhör gegenüberzusitzen
in sein herz auszuschütten und ihn
wieder und wieder zu erklären wie es kam
dass er es in der sms nur bis zum oberen
sturmbannführer gebracht hat dass es
nicht an ihm gelegen habe dass er nicht
vorankam er hat prinzipiell ganz gut
gewusst worum es ging und einem
schlusswort vor gericht und der
staatlicherseits vorgeschriebenen
umwertung der werte gesprochen er war
nicht dumm
er war gewissermaßen es war
gewissermaßen schiere gedankenlosigkeit
etwas was mit dummheit keineswegs
identisch ist die interpretierte zu
einem der größten verbrecher derzeit zu
werden ja das ist jetzt die spannende
frage also die these wie stellt jetzt an
die person als man es vor wird
diskutiert danach noch genauer darüber
sie sagt er war kein typischer bösewicht
er
war er hatte keine motive er wollte gar
nicht das böse tun und er war sogar eher
kleinliche war ein kleingeist weiler mit
seinem schicksal als obersturmbannführer
gehadert hat er war eigentlich ein
kleiner karrierist
und hat sich wahrlich nicht als ein
bösewicht geeignet wir in literarischen
fiktionen vorkommt also das böse was ich
an ihm manifestiert dass es irgendwie
von anderer art als dasjenige was wird
zumindest aus erzählungen kennen gerade
zeiler weise unsere bisherigen begriffe
die genügen hier nicht ihn zu verstehen
gleich sagt sie noch hier ein mangel des
vorstellungsvermögen hatte auch gab
und erlebt unter shearer
gedankenlosigkeit was mit dummheit nicht
zu verwechseln ist gedankenlosigkeit ja
hat jetzt hat man das böse was er tat
also was war denn das böse das war die
organisation die planmäßig organisation
eines völkermords vom schreibtisch aus
hat er diese organisation gedankenlos
getan waren da nicht ja gedanklich
involviert hat er sich da gar nichts
vorstellen können das ist die frage das
klingt doch so ein bisschen so als sei
das einfach nur so ein kleines rädchen
im getriebe gewesen so ein typischer
schreibtischtäter das gibt es ja diese
kategorie ja das liegt jetzt ein
bisschen nach wir werden gleich sehen
das hannah arendt nicht die these
vertritt dass
man ein schreibtischtäter war oder dass
er irgendwie davon in schutz genommen
werden könnte aber das thema
gedankenlosigkeit das klingt auch so als
sei einfach irgendwie in seinem denken
nicht ganz bei der sache gewesen es hat
jetzt allerdings neue entdeckung gegeben
die so genannten so protokolle die man
aufgezeichnet hatte wo er mit einem
anderen mann über sein verbrechen sprach
und diese protokolle bettina stangneth
eine philosophin hat diese protokolle
ausgewertet
in ihrem buch eichmann vor jerusalem
also da gibt es jetzt neue quellen die
hannah arendt noch nicht bekannt gewesen
waren als diesen bericht über die
banalität des bösen verfasste und diesen
protokollen wird eben deutlich dass
eigentlich man genau wusste was er tat
und dass er dann vor gericht eine rolle
gespielt hat er hat also die rolle des
unwissenden des harmlosen des banalen
gespielt also manche sagen hand ist hab
ich mal auf den leim gegangen sie hat
ihm seine rolle abgenommen als kleines
rädchen im getriebe was irgendwie ja
nicht so ganz
gedanklich bei der sache war was einfach
nicht weit genug gedacht hat was da
alles passieren könnte das hat man also
jetzt ein bisschen vorgeworfen ich
glaube dennoch dass man die werden und
banalität des bösen im sinn verstehen
kann der und sich an unserem seminar
diskussion anschließt und vor allem
insofern als diese banalität des bösen
mit dem schein charakter des bösen
verbindung gebracht werden kann mit der
wirkung ist auch schon zu tun hatten in
diesem semester an verschiedenen dieser
weiter und dandys banal ist und sogar
komisch wenn man ihnen nämlich beim
besten willen keine teuflisch dämonische
tiefe abgewinnen kann so ist es darum
doch noch lange nicht alltäglich dass du
es ist banal warum es ist banal weiß
kann tiefen hat aber es kein
alltägliches ist dürfte gar nicht so oft
vorkommen dass einem menschen im
angesicht des todes und noch dazu unter
dem galgen also es war die situation
vielleicht mann er wurde dann erhängt zu
strafen nichts anderes einfällt als was
er
beerdigung
sein leben lang zu hören bekommen hat
auf beerdigung wahrscheinlich und das
über diesen erhebenden worten die
wirklichkeit des eigenen todes unschwer
vergessen kann dass eine solche
realitätsferne und gedankenlosigkeit in
einem mehr unheil anrichten können als
alle die den menschen vielleicht ihnen
wohnen den bösen triebe zusammengenommen
das war in der tat die lektion die man
in jerusalem lernen konnte aber es war
eine lektion und weder eine erklärung
des phänomens noch eine theorie dahinter
als hier finden jetzt ganz zentrale
passagen das ist vielleicht das
zentralste zitat von anna abend über die
banalität des bösen erstens mal sagt sie
was sie die banalität des bösen hand ist
keine theorie über das böse
und es ist auch keine erklärung des
phänomens das bösen sondern es ist nur
eine lektion
wir können uns fragen was ist denn eine
lektion eine lektion ist ein bankspieler
hier gibt jemand uns eine lektion hat
und sie mit eine lektion erteilt hier
hat konnten wir beispielhaft sehen
personifiziert wie das böse irgendwie
angetan alle form annehmen kann man
haben wollte jetzt keine theorie darüber
verfassen das müssen wir jetzt versuchen
daraus und bis in der theorie zu machen
er sagt sogar sie sagt sogar dass dieses
banale komisch zahl also vielleicht
grotesk weil man nie meine ich man keine
teuflisch dämonische tiefe abgewinnen
kann
aber sie ist dennoch nicht alltäglicher
also eichmann ist einfach wenn man mal
das bild sieht ich hab's vorgestellt
wohin auf dem titelbild dieses buches
sieht er aus wie ein ganz gewöhnlicher
etwas älterer mann vielleicht 60 so
sieht nicht aus wie ein thema aber das
ist jetzt ja auch nicht so besonders
dass man das böse natürlich nicht
äußerlich anzieht
und jetzt kommt aber das entscheidende
spricht von einer realitätsferne und von
einer gedankenlosigkeit die eichmann
auszeit und diese realitätsferne
gedankenlosigkeit die können mehr unheil
anrichten als
die bösen triebe zusammengenommen ja das
ist so die pont also gedankenlosigkeit
realitätsferne sind nicht harmlos
sondern können sich unglaublich böse
auswirken das müssen wir uns genauer
fragen wie man das zu verstehen hat ja
noch mal ein längeres zitat möchte ich
aber auch noch vorlesen nur zum teil
nicht weniger beunruhigend war dieser
bisher unbekannte verbrecher typus
also das ist ein unbekannter verbrecher
typus und es ist auch die unbekannte art
des verbrechens das hier zur verhandlung
stand
es geht also auch um ein neues
verbrechen das muss man sich jetzt
fragen wie kann man das denn
angemessen verstehen ja hier sie bringt
verschiedene
begriffe ins spiel sie sagt in der
antike
waren völkermorde an der tagesordnung
und die jahrhunderte der kolonisation
und des imperialismus kennen mehr oder
minder die glückte versuchen diese
richtung zu genügen um aus dem
englischen intervall ismus stammende
ausdruck verwaltungs massenmord ministry
of musicals den die engländer bewusst
ablehnten als ein mittel die herrschaft
über in den häufig zu halten dürfte der
sache erheblich angemessene sein und
zudem den vorteil haben dass
solche ungeheuerlichkeiten nur ein
freundlich volk oder einer anders
gearteten rasse gegenüber möglich sind
also es geht hier jetzt um die frage wie
man dieses verbrechen des holocaust
begrifflich fassen kann sie bringt jetzt
zumindest schon mal diesen auszug
verwaltungs massenmord ins spiel und
hier ist ein wichtiger punkt genannt
nämlich die verwaltung also die
administration die verwaltung sozusagen
das böse den mann zu bringen das böse
kann verwaltet werden das sieht man
anhand von eichmann weil eichmann
einfach ein verwalter war er war der
typus des verwalters er selbst hat ja
nie wirklich menschen direkt getötet er
stand ja einfach nur hinter den
prozessen und hat das im hintergrund
organisiert hat da konnte er sich
natürlich immer so ein bisschen selbst
belügen und sagen ich tue doch
eigentlich gar nichts also das ist ja
diese dieses handliche verwaltungs
dimension des bösen das scheint auch so
ein bisschen was neues zu sein der
verwaltungs bösewicht sozusagen
in jerusalem kam diese sache ungenügend
zur sprache weil sie juristisch in der
tat sehr schwer fassbar ist und die
hörten beteuerung der verteidigung als
man sei doch nur ein winziges rädchen im
getriebe der endlösung gewesen und die
meinung der staatsanwaltschaft dient
eigentlich mal den eigentlichen motor
entdecken zu können glaubte ich selbst
habe diese theorien ebenso wenig
bedeutung beigemessen wie das ewz
jerusalem gericht und der ersten instanz
da die ganze rad theorie juristisch
belanglos ist und es daher ganz
gleichgültig war in welcher
größenordnung anders eichmann
unterbringen wollte also jetzt kommt
diese rat theorie finde ich ganz gut
bezeichnet ich bin doch nur ein kleines
rädchen im getriebe
auf mich kommt doch gar nicht an ja was
kann man jetzt darauf an man könnte
sagen in einer großen maschine jede sein
verwaltungsprozess sozusagen des bösen
da kommt eben doch auf jedes kleine
rädchen an dass es sich richtig dreht
weil wenn ein kleines redlich aus dem
gesamten komplex entnommen wird dann
funktioniert das ganze nicht mehr also
jede beteiligte instanz konnte sich
einreden und sagen ich bin doch nur ein
kleines rädchen im getriebe aber
zusammengenommen
war dann eben doch wieder daran
beteiligt auch wenn er noch ein so
kleines vermeintliches mädchen war auch
die
metaphorik rädchen er legte nahe dass
man nur so ein ausführendes organ war
dass man nur so ein kleines mechanisches
teilchen war also hier klickt schon in
der wortwahl nahe dass man sich selbst
für gegenständlich und das sagt sie
jetzt auch hier dass es im wesen des
totalen herrschafts apparates und
vielleicht in natur der bürokratie legt
aus menschen funktionäre und lose räder
im verwaltungsbetrieb zu machen und sie
damit zu und menschlichen ist für
bedeutung für die politik und
sozialwissenschaften ja aber das ist der
punkt also menschen werden in solchen im
verwaltungssystemen auch irgendwie
entmenschlicht oder sie glauben sich
selbst in menschlichen zu können dem
sieben nur kleine rädchen im getriebe
sind also man neigt dazu in solchen
systemen seine eigene personalität
aufzugeben das ist ein generelles
problem der modernen gesellschaft dass
in solchen großen systemen ja
entmenschlichung stattfindet und dass
vielleicht solche menschlichen system
dann auch umso mehr zu entmenschlichung
beitragen weil sie eben dann ihre opfer
nach genau dem selben prinzip der
verwaltungs maschinerie behandeln
einfach nicht lose nummer die opfer
werden zu blusen nummern gemacht und so
war das ja auch dann am ende
ja das ist also hier noch mal der punkt
ist sehen und jetzt kann man noch kurz
auf diese schrift über das böse zu
sprechen
in der sie auch sehr scharfsinnig eine
psychologie des bösen gibt sie sagt
niemand böse sein das haben wir
behandelt bei kant und fichte ich mach
oben rechts noch mal den link hin zu
kant wo kann sagt dass wir nicht das
lösung des bösen willen tun können
niemand will böse sein und jene die
trotzdem böse handeln fallen ihnen
absurde moral in moralische absurdität
der das tut befindet sich eigentlich im
widerspruch mit sich selbst mit seinem
eigenen verstand man muss sich deshalb
in kans worten selbst verachten dass
diese furcht vor der selbstverachtung
wohl kaum ausreichen würde um
gesetzlichkeit zu garantieren ist
offensichtlich doch solange sie in einer
gesellschaft von gesetzes treuen drücken
sich gebieten nahmen sie irgendwie an
dass es mit zehn zu acht umgehen würde
kann natürlich wusste dass es mit
selbstverachtung besser mit der furcht
sich selbst beachten müssen oft nicht
gehen und seine erklärung hierfür war
dass der mensch sich selbst belügen kann
deshalb hat er wiederholt erklärt dass
der wirklich vom fleck in der mensch die
natur die verlogenheit das vermögen zu
lügen sein und das ist ganz interessant
und am ende bringt sie ein bezug auf die
brüder karamasow
von dostojewski und da fragt der dimitri
den star auf was muss ich tun um erlöst
zu werden woraufhin das darauf erwidert
vor allem die lüge die ich nicht selbst
also hier haben wieder die form der löse
aber die lücke was ist denn die lüge das
ist die selbsttäuschung hat es also die
erzeugung von schein und das hatten wir
schon in verschiedenen stellen gesehen
bekannt aber auch bei fichte und wir
hatten sogar in der letzten sitzung
gesehen als wir es mit hegel zu tun
hatten wo häkel auch sagt das böse hat
was mit dem schalen zu tun also da ist
sie ganz im zentrum was mich allerdings
etwas wundert ist dass sie hier nicht
ausführlicher auf augustinus zwischen
kommt weil doch augustinus gerade diese
möglichkeit böse zu sein um das bösen
willen ausführlich in seinen
bekenntnissen am beispiel des diebstahls
diskutiert hat also das ist etwas
merkwürdig sie muss ihn doch so gut
gekannt haben warum hat sie ihn dann
hier nicht angehören das wäre doch auch
mal spannend ja jetzt kommt hier noch
mal eine anknüpfung an diesen bericht
über die banalität des bösen aus dem wir
ein zitat gelesen hatte hatten wo sie
eben sagte dass der grund der banalität
von eichmann die gedankenlosigkeit sei
also diese diese bzw eigentlich diese
verwandelte vorstellungskraft die ist ja
nicht genau dasselbe wie
gedankenlosigkeit also dass hier
irgendwie es mit unserem denken
jedenfalls zu tun hat und jetzt sagt sie
in diesen buchen angefunkt daran die
größten übeltäter sind jene die sich
nicht erinnern weil sie auf das getan
niemals gedanken verschwendet haben und
ohne erinnerungen kann nichts sie
zurückhaltend das denken an vergangene
angelegenheiten bedeutet für menschliche
ließen sich in die dimension der tiefe
zu begeben wurzeln zu schlagen und sich
selbst zu stabilisieren so dass man
nicht bei allem möglichen die zeitgeist
wie geschichte oder einfach der
versuchung hinweg geschwemmt wird und
jetzt kommt eine zentrale passage
zentrales zitat das größte böse ist
nicht radikal
es hat keine wurzeln und weil es keine
wurzeln hat hat es keine grenzen kann
sich nun voll stellen extrem entwickeln
und über die ganze welt aus passte das
ist jetzt eine starke these
hier ist die frage ob sie sich jetzt
genau auf ganz begriff des radikal bösen
bezieht kann sagt ja das böse ist
verwurzelt und zwar eben in jedem
menschen
es scheint hier nicht genau das zum
einen weil
damit ist ja bekannt nicht gesagt dass
es dagegen dass man gegen den zeitgeist
dadurch die moni sei dadurch dass man
radikal böse wird sie meint hier wohl
was anderes ja also eine tiefe eine
tiefendimension
und das sagt sie eine tiefendimension
das fehlt die bösen also das böse ist
oberflächliches bleibt an der oberfläche
und weil es an der oberfläche ist kann
es durch den zeitgeist der geschichte
mobilisiert werden und es kann sich vor
allem weil es nicht verwurzelt ist
unbegrenzt ausdehnen und am ende sogar
die ganze welt betrifft das ist eine
spannende these das böse als wurzel
haftungs oder als wurzel loses phänomen
haben also ich denke nicht dass man es
direkt im gegensatz zu kant verstehen
darf weil kant damit dass nur sagen
wollte wir sind alle immer schon böse
kant wollte dann bin ich sagen mit dem
begriff das radikal bösen dass wir
eine tiefendimension besonders haben die
uns irgendwie
stabilisiert oder sowas das ist nicht
der direkte bezug wie mir scheint auf
kant
genau ja die folien stelle ich nachher
auch noch rein auf elias
weiter sagt sie ich erwähnte dass das
person sein unterschieden wäre von nur
menschlich zahlen die griechen sich das
lagern von den barbaren als logisch und
von den barbaren absetzen und sagte es
wäre beinahe redundant von einer
moralischen persönlichkeit zu sprechen
wenn wir unseren sokrates rechtfertigung
seiner moralischen behauptung als
beispiel halten könnten wir jetzt sagen
dass ich mich diesem denkprozess in dem
ich die spezifisch menschlich differenz
der sprache aktualisieren klar als
person konstituieren und dass ich eine
bleibe in dem maß in dem ich immer
wieder und immer neue zu einer solchen
konstituierung fähig bin wenn es das ist
was für gewöhnlich persönlichkeiten hin
das hat nichts zu tun mit blick auf die
intelligenz dann ist sie das einfache
beinahe automatische ergebnis von
nachdenklichkeit anders gesagt wenn
vergeben wird dann wird nicht das
verbrechen vergebens an die person eine
wurzel losen bösen gibt es keine person
mehr der mann je vergeben könnte das ist
ganz spart also hier im wurzellos und
bösen im banalen bösen ist die frage im
modernen bösen durch
maschinerien der organisation da gibt es
gar keine personen mehr die dahinter
stehen die man den mann vergeben kann
die frage ist dann kann man sich auch
wirklich dann urteilen das ist eine
andere frage aber sie will damit sagen
die person verschwindet wenn man eben
nur noch ein rädchen im getriebe ist
diese tiefendimension die sie vermisst
bei eichmann die ist für sie ein
ausdruck eines solchen
maschinellen geradezu maschinellen
verwaltungsapparats nach apparates eine
maschine und da gibt jeder sagt sie
seine personalien auf und dadurch kann
sie das böse umso mehr vielleicht auch
maschinell ausbreiten weil es nicht mehr
an tiefendimensionen von personen
gebunden ist die darüber auch kritisch
reflektieren könnten und sich aus
geschichte berufen könnten die sich an
erinnerungen berufen könnten an waren
wie beispiele aus der
literaturgeschichte zum beispiel das
sagt sie geht alles nicht mehr
hier ist noch dann ganz interessanter
punkt zum schluss das betrifft die moral
psychologie also es gibt die these dass
viele der verbrechen im
nationalsozialismus eigentlich ganz
normale menschen war ganz normal im
sinne dass sie im alltag nicht weiter
aufgefallen sind und darauf geht es
jetzt ein sie sagt aber obwohl sie
scheinbar normal sind diese täter kann
man doch etwas an ihnen feststellen was
sie so gefährlich gemacht hat und jetzt
lese ich das höre lassen sie nämlich
abschließend an jene mütter im dritten
reich erinnern die nicht nur ein
mustergültiges familienleben führten
sind auch ihre freizeit gerne damit
verbracht hölderlin zu lesen und bach zu
finden damit bewiesen als ob beweise
hier führt dafür gefehlt das
intellektuelle ebenso einfach in
verbrechen hineingezogen werden können
wie jeder andere auch man könnte doch
jetzt denkt intellektuelle menschen
gebildete menschen studierte menschen
die sind immun gegen das böse weil sie
so gescheit sind und sie sagt nein
verstand bildung zumindest diese bildung
die diese menschen hatten
die kann davor nicht uns bewahren
aber sind nicht die sensibilität und ein
gefühl für die so genannten höheren
dinge im leben geistige fähigkeiten ganz
bestimmt und diese
fähigkeit muss fähigkeit heißen
ausgeschlossen ist ein hat ganze gar
nichts mit den blick zu tun dass wir uns
erinnern soll eine tätigkeit ist und
nicht der passive genuss von etwas alles
sagt es geht nicht darum dass wir ein
geschmack entwickelt für die schönen
dinge für schöne musik schöne kunst das
ist nur was rezept iwes das ist nur eine
aufgeschlossenheit eine offenheit für
gewisse kultur kulturelle fakten sind
sie sagt es geht um eine tätigkeit und
nicht um den passiv - also denken sagt
sie ist immer was aktiv ist und nicht
nur sich berieseln lassen oder
kunstausstellungen besuchen die frage
ist ob man kunstausstellung immer nur
passiv besucht oder ob sich da nicht
auch ganz fehlen uns aktiv verzeichnis
lassen wir dahingestellt sagt weiter
insofern als denken eine tätigkeit ist
kann es im produkt übertragen werden
solche dinge wie gedichte musikstücke
oder gemeldet alle dinge dieser art
tatsächlich gedanken die mir genauso wie
möbel und gegenstände unseres täglichen
gebrauchs mit recht als
gebrauchsgegenstände bezeichnet werden
das ist die praxis und die tories ist
darüber hat eine art auch sehr viel
geschrieben über die art der aktivität
die einen sind durch denken die anderen
durch gebrauch durch bestimmte
menschliche bedürfnisse und wünsche
zusammengekommen die sache bei diesen
hoch kultivierten hören ist die dass
nicht ein einziger von ihnen ein gericht
schrieb das es wert wäre dass man sich
daran erinnerte oder ein hörenswertes
musikstück komponiert oder ein bild mit
über dem öl die man gelegen wäre es an
seinem land zu hängen ja man braucht
mehr als nachdenklichkeit um ein gutes
gedicht oder musikstück zu schreiben
oder ein bild zu malen sie brauchen also
besondere talente aber kein talent wird
mit dem verlust wird dem verlust der
integrität stadtteil und integrität die
verliehen sie verlieren wenn sie diese
ganz allgemeine ding und
erinnerungsfähigkeit verloren haben das
ist spannend jetzt macht sie eine
ästhetische theorie sagt
böse menschen banal böse menschen die
können nicht wirkliche kunst produzieren
weil sie
nicht integer sind
weil sie ihr ding und
erinnerungsfähigkeit verloren haben das
müsste man jetzt mal versuchen empirisch
zu überprüfen gibt es von
personen die viel böses getan haben
kunstwerke die große kunst sind mir
persönlich leute das erst mal nicht ein
dass ich sehe jetzt nicht den grund
warum das in der kunst sich so zeigen
sollte wie leser diskutieren gleich
darüber also unmittelbar leuchtet mir
das noch nicht ein dass man einem
kunstwerk ansehen kann dass die person
die dahintersteht potenziell böse ist
und weil die kunst ist ja immer auch mit
scheinen zu tun hat die kunst lebt ja
mit shine ich habe in diesem buch
theorien des bösen sehr viel über
geschrieben über die ästhetik sie
scheint auf den ersten blick zumindest
sie ist eine moralisierung der ästhetik
zu betreiben und hier stellt sich wieder
die frage nach dem verhältnis von ethik
und ästhetik
also ist kunst moralisch irgendwie
signifikant oder nicht und hier scheiden
sich die geister ich möchte einfach nur
problematisieren möchte jetzt nicht
definitiv irgendwie auch die eine oder
andere seite schlagen möchte nur sagen
das verhältnis von ästhetik und ethik
ist problematisch dass muss man auf
jeden fall sagt aber ihre these ist dass
ihm solche leute wie adolf eichmann weil
sie eben nur aufgeschlossen waren aber
keine tätigkeit des denkens betrieben
haben dass sie deswegen zwar hoch
kultiviert waren aber eben nicht ein
wirklich gutes gedicht oder musikstück
herzustellen waren weil sie kein tief
ist denkt und
erinnerungsvermögen oder keine fähigkeit
dazu hat ja das war es jetzt in der
heutigen sitzung eine spannende theorie
meine these ist dass die banalität des
bösen nicht so verstanden werden sollte
dass das duell selbst banal ist sondern
dass das böse den schein der qualität
erzeugt also adolf eichmann und das
haben auch die neueren forschungen von
bettina stangneth ergeben der hat er
einfach eine rolle gespielt die rolle
des kleinen mädchens er wusste genau was
er tat das heißt er hat sich den schein
der banalität verliehen war natürlich
aber darin selbst keineswegs banal und
dieser schein charakter der sich auch in
diesem jahr
tötungsmaschinerie der bürokratie zeit
der ist doch wieder ganz typisch wird es
böse wie wir anhand von verschiedenen
theorien bisher gesehen nachdem wir
jetzt sehr viel über das böse gesprochen
haben wollen wir ein bisschen mehr der
nächsten sitzung auf das gute eingehen
und zwar ist hier der text von philipp
einer neueren angelsächsischen
philosophin jüngeren angelsächsischen
philosophen ein buch mit dem titel die
natur des guten und darin wir die these
vertreten dass die natur also die
organischer natur wie wir sie hier auch
sehen dass die selbst eine normativität
impliziert dass die natur selbst die
kriterien hat für auch moralisch gut und
böse und das zeigt sie daran dass
gewisse tiere
normgerecht fungieren oder nicht
normgerecht fungieren und sie versucht
aus dieser natürlichen normativität eine
moralische normativität vielleicht nicht
direkt abzuleiten aber doch sensibel das
ist eine spannende these die jetzt
wieder so ein bisschen mehr auf das gute
abzielt nachdem wir hier sehr viel über
das böse gesprochen hatten man kann sich
natürlich auch fragen wie ist denn das
gute bei hannah arendt zu verstehen wenn
das böse wurzellos ist dann muss das
gute wohl wurzel haft zahlen das ist so
die these also wenn das böse keine
wurzeln hat nicht
tiefsinnig ist kein aktives denkvermögen
bedeutet dann muss das gute eben gerade
diese fehlenden eigenschaften haben man
kann sich fragen vertritt hannah arendt
eine prävention theorie des bösen also
ist die privaten des bösen dadurch bei
einer abend vorhanden dass es sich
einfach ein mangel ist an denkfähigkeit
ein mangel ist an vorstellungswelt kalt
oder werden hier nicht viel mehr ganz
andere arten von denken produziert wie
zb so ein sch ein denken das möchte ich
mal dahingestellt lassen spannende these
provokative these der banalität des
bösen und dann bedanke ich mich vielmals
für die aufmerksamkeit